-Our next guest
is a very funny actress,
comedian, and writer
you know from shows like
"Parks and Recreation"
and films like "Obvious Child."
She stars in "The Great North."
The second season premieres
this Sunday night on -- on Fox.
Excuse me.
Let's take a look.
-[ Sighs ]
-Uh-oh. A flop and a sigh.
What's going on, Jude?
-Ever since Dr. Gary
said I'm getting my braces off,
I've felt...sad?
-Well, you were always gonna
get them off eventually.
It's a part of growing up.
-Like learning
to shave your legs and then
not caring enough to do it.
-But, Judy, once your teeth are
out of those little wire jails,
you can do anything.
Day after I got mine off, I went
right over to the car dealership
and, through a series
of miscommunications,
got trapped in a car trunk
for three days.
-I guess I better
go look in the mirror
and sigh a little bit more.
-Please welcome back
to the show,
one of our favorites,
Jenny Slate!
How are you, Jenny?
-Hi, Seth!
Ooh!
[ Laughter ]
Sorry. Nope.
I don't know, whatever.
-I like that.
I think that energy was right.
And not at all weird.
-Right?
Well, I mean, I would love --
Okay. Hi, Seth.
Hi. That's really
a nice way to say "hi."
Hi. I have a new baby,
and it seems like
now when I say "hi" to adults,
I say "hi" the way
that I do to my baby.
And, like, so, a normal "hi"
for me at this point is like,
[ Gasps ]
"Ooh! Hi!
Who just woke up?"
-This is very exciting.
You had baby Ida in December,
correct?
-I did.
I had her kind of like
just a few days, I feel like,
after I last spoke with you.
-Yes, you were very -- you
showed your belly on our show,
which we really appreciated
seeing, because it did look
like an any-day-now situation.
-Yeah, the baby came out.
-Yeah.
And how has it been?
-The stork did not come.
It's really nice.
[ Laughter ]
It's super nice to have a baby.
I am, like, more tired than
I have ever, ever, ever been
or known that a person
could be, like --
Like, you know when
you're so tired that
other things like you, like,
just put your head on a table
and you're like,
"This could be a bed"?
Like everything seems
like it could be a bed.
-Yep.
Are you finding time --
I know one of the hardest
things, you know, for Lexi,
when she gave birth was, like,
just finding time to, like,
eat and do stuff like that.
-Let me tell you, the other day,
I was on the telephone.
I called up to speak
to someone at your show,
and they were like,
"'Late Night.'
Hold for one moment."
And I was like, "Oh, cool!"
20 seconds maybe, I shoved half
a chicken thigh in my mouth.
That's how I eat now.
It's like half of an animal,
and I'm standing up,
and the whole time I go,
"Sorry, sorry.
Sorry. Sorry."
So, yeah, I find the time.
I do. I find it.
-It must be both great
to be able to do voiceover work
right now on a show like this,
because you don't have to worry
about all the COVID protocols,
but the negative must be
that you never get to interact
with a cast that is so talented.
-It's such a bummer because,
also, we started in the studio.
So, like, you know how not --
we know how much fun
it could have been.
I like to compare it to my
shellfish and avocado allergy,
which is like, there was a time
when I ingested it a lot,
and I was like, "Oh, these
things are very delicious,"
and then suddenly I got, like,
crazy explosive diarrhea,
and I could
never have them again.
Not that I'm allergic to our
cast, but now we're over Zoom --
But I will say it's really nice
because you have that energy
of, like, people that
are super eager to perform.
-Yes.
-That like jacked-up energy
and then also all of the squares
of the Fox executives
that just have their names
and they're just, like, lurking.
-Do you like the lurkers?
-Yeah, I mean,
I hate to admit it.
I never thought that
that could be something
I would get into,
but I'm just like,
"I wonder what Todd
is thinking about this."
[ Laughter ]
"What does Todd look like?
Like, is he chuckling?
He's so withholding.
I'll never know.
I better floor it
with my performance."
[ Laughter ]
-You -- Your character,
we found out,
was obsessed
with Alanis Morissette,
and you got to meet via Zoom.
Was it via Zoom
that you met Alanis?
-No, it was in person.
-You met her in person.
That is outstanding.
Now, I know
she was a big deal to you.
Did you keep your cool?
-I mean, what do you think?
You know,
you know me a little bit.
[ Both laugh ]
-I think you are smart enough
and aware enough
to at least go in
with the preparation
of trying not to lose your cool.
-For sure, of course.
I was like, "Today, Alanis will
be at the table read.
Let's -- You know,
I don't need to, like,
wear my
"Jagged Little Pill" shirt.
I can wear a blue turtleneck,
so that she'll think, like,
that I'm all --
I'm, like, just normal.
I'm just waking up.
I didn't, like, shoot out of bed
and hit the ceiling
because Alanis
will be in the same room."
And I will also say, I don't
really like to meet, like,
people that I admire.
-Mm-hmm.
-Because --
Because if it goes wrong,
then the whole thing
is, like, ruined forever.
Like, I one time
met this jazz singer
who I really liked,
who was very old.
And now she is deceased,
not that that's part of this,
but it's a part of life.
-Yes.
[ Both laugh ]
-So, you know,
we all go eventually.
But I, like, had my little CD,
because this was in the past,
and I went up to her,
and I was like,
"I just want you to know, your
music means so much to me."
And this, like, tiny little
old lady looked over
to the other like 100-year-old
person next to her and went,
"Oh, brother!"
[ Laughter ]
I was like...
[ Gasping ]
And so, I was afraid to meet
Alanis in case she hated me
like that old woman did hate me
before she died.
-Yeah.
-And, um --
And so I was like,
"Just don't do anything.
Just sit next to Alanis
and just don't do anything.
Just say your lines."
And so I went in there,
I sat next to Alanis,
and I was like --
[ Laughing ]
"I love you so much!
Would you want to take
a picture with m-e-e?!"
And, um -- And she did.
And she did,
and we took a selfie.
-Okay, good.
So that one had a happy ending.
-Yeah, yeah.
I mean, the picture is uncool.
-Gotcha. But at least --
It's like proof of life.
You did meet her,
and you can prove it to people.
-Yeah. For sure.
I can prove it
if I want to show a picture
of Alanis looking normal
and me going...
[ Laughter ]
Like, flared nostrils,
like weird, as if I have an itch
and I'm trying to make a face
to make it go away
rather than scratch it.
Like, it's just
not a good picture.
But I have the picture,
and Alanis is really nice,
of course.
-You -- I want
to close by asking this.
I know that you have been
trying to get married,
and COVID has been throwing
wrench after wrench
in your plans.
But you were kind of --
You might be pulling it off,
finally.
-Yeah, that's true.
We've cancelled three times.
Not because of arguments
but because of a pandemic,
which is a lovely way
to cancel your wedding.
-Yeah.
-And I think we're gonna do it
just in a much smaller way,
like, in our living room.
That's the way now.
-We've talked in the past
about how one of your
favorite things about weddings
is when the bride surprises
the groom with a song
that she has written about him,
and how the groom
is, in the moment,
devastated it's happening.
Have you thought about
doing this for Ben?
-Oh, you know, yeah.
I mean, when your wedding
gets ruined three times,
you're like,
"Let's just kill this thing."
You know, like, I --
And just to --
What I -- Just to say,
I don't dislike it when someone,
like, sings a song with --
Like, I was at a wedding.
A bride sang a song
with the groom on the piano.
I was like, "This is
a wonderful version of this."
What I don't like is, like,
bride at the top
of a staircase --
Why is there
a staircase in your venue?
Mic -- wireless mic
and singing a specific song
just like...
♪ Troy, I let you go
on the fishing trip with Kevin ♪
♪ Because you know
that I trust you ♪
♪ Trust is essential ♪
Or whatever, and it's just like,
"This isn't for him."
That bothered me.
-If you --
Would you like to rehearse
or at least show us
a little taste of what --
if you did this --
what you would sing to Ben?
-Yeah, because here's the thing.
I already had the baby.
-Yeah.
-You know?
So, it's like he's here.
So I feel like,
instead of it being like...
♪ When I met you,
it was summer ♪
♪ A beautiful season ♪
...or whatever.
If you like summer.
It would more be like...
♪ Ben, you saw me poop
in the barf bag ♪
♪ Because I couldn't
get to the bathroom ♪
♪ When the baby exploded
from my vag-i-i-ina ♪
♪ I love you, baby ♪
Right?
-I think everyone
in that living room
will jump to their feet
if you sing that song.
-Yeah, I mean, I'm gonna be --
even though it's gonna be
in our living room,
and I'm not gonna need
that amplification,
I'm gonna be on the mic.
-You're gonna be
on a wireless mic.
I think
that's an excellent call.
Hey, Jenny, it's always
so lovely to see you.
Thanks so much for being here.
-Thanks for having me, Seth.
-The second season of
"The Great North" premieres this
Sunday at 8:30 p.m. on Fox.